thank you ted we appreciate it i
appreciate the updates and if you have a
sweet tooth
you're gonna love this yo nuts an
over-the-top doughnut and ice cream shop
is opening their first las vegas
location in centennial hills
let's welcome to the kitchen tony and
jordan with younuts welcome guys first
question is the name we're debating in
the office what does this mean
you nuts what's the story behind the
name you know that's you know we wanted
to think of something fun something
memorable something that people could
just have fun with so you know
it was awesome and what makes your
donuts
so special so you know what we have
donuts we have ice cream but
what makes us special is we combine them
we do crazy things with them we just
whatever we can think of we do and we
come up with these awesome fantastical
desserts
so we've got a doughnut we've got ice
cream mixed together is that the smash
stone at that time
walk me through these donuts so what
what are we going on here so smash donut
what we do is we take a doughnut cut it
in half
put some ice cream inside we smash it
together we hot press it put a bunch of
toppings on it
and then uh we serve it they look just
like that they're gorgeous beautiful
lots of fun to uh yes i am do you have
some other toppings you can put on top
of these doughnuts here i see some extra
toppings
yeah absolutely so so this is our
nutella crunch uh winner
crunch winner of dessert wars yeah you
guys are two-time winners
the only brand that ever done that so we
um we brought the nutella crunch
made and i'm also gonna make one right
here for you so uh so basically we just
take this nutella now this is already
smashed and
we have the uh as you're making this
here jordan tell me about the grand
opening it's taking place tomorrow and
there's a lot going on out there yeah so
we have a grand opening taking place
tomorrow at 10 a.m
centennial hills and road to the 95
we're super excited to bring it to uh
the first door to las vegas so uh we
hope everybody comes and uh
there's gonna be great prizes out there
and a dj we have we're doing giveaways
every 15 minutes we have a live dj
face paintings going on and uh yeah
we're inviting everybody to come out and
kind of you know come join the fun and
come see what we're all about i want to
point something out you two are too
impressive man
i mean tony you're in amazing shape
you're both in fantastic shape and you
live off of donuts that's how great
these donuts don't have a diet donut
diet
just like some of the smaller ones you
know because you guys sent some over and
you got it so these are minis so we have
mini donuts as well
and they're uh they're really awesome
i don't think you're going to be shy
which one should i go look at the box
you tell me which one i should try and
what makes it so special
dunkaroo the dunkaroo that's my favorite
the little uh
this one here on top yep and what's on
top a little teddy bear man
[Applause]
that's pretty good there's a double
punch of flavor yeah it's delicious now
one location so far in las vegas more to
come yes
absolutely more to come you can make
gift cards tomorrow too right first 50
people
we actually yeah yeah so tomorrow the
first 50 people in line will have a
chance to win a uh we'll have uh
to get a chance for a smash donut just
be in line at 10 a.m and uh
we'll be handing them out so yeah we got
some smash cash that we've been passing
around uh this is good for free uh free
things like
this
these donors are so good these are
absolutely delicious gentlemen thank you
so much we appreciate it yeah